oops No hello and welcome to this video
I'm in dhimahi I mean they're mine
hey you don't know how this is
pronounced I've got an Iran flag
so probably Scott for nights no should
be foreigners plate
[Music]
hmm it's a very odd way of playing it
and as usual very quickly decided and
let's play a weird setup without
thinking about it I don't know probably
not it's not lost for black or anything
but it looks a bit odd where does the
bishop gone to d6 okay I don't want him
to take on d5 so I probably just got
back so a d5 census night back to square
one and now if if five is interesting
preventing d6 okay d6 he cannot play
anyway but so let's develop first
and this is not that terrible actually
for black so it's a playable position
that same
[Music]
we'll try to play on the sea for him
f4 is going to take player 5 that's not
really what I'd like to do I'm going to
stop any f5 you were play Bishop d6 that
was to be expected
Roxy one and now maybe I just take kind
of stick yeah that's an interesting
question now if I should take this or
not you have a this is a bit like a
Benoni and b6 can be weak actually like
it should be two and aim for a form
takes pawn takes it's also a little bit
better for Wyatt it's tough to say what
to do him here I'm better because any of
those the pawns are just a bit weak it's
not the end of the world for black but
the structural issues remain that's
interesting
I need to quickly regroup there to make
sure this this is going you cannot play
against the knight on d4
okay so hmm we should be five I'm not
sure about all this or should I just
play a three a three is a bit weakening
but I probably need additional support
for the e4 pawn
yeah fairly normally I'm trying to put
more pressure on that d6 born okay um
yeah Queen g5 threatened see five
why should I come back actually I mean
if I would have threatened anyway but
okay
once I have Quincy's six like if he goes
h6 I go Quincy six he's still lush
usually had on the clock because he
dashed out all those somewhat
questionable moves very quickly the
other points is gone yeah we win it at
least I think maybe you can try to
simplify down with before you know after
before I can go a for probably do
yeah okay
grab this I wonder rock or queen look
group chicks is probably giving me a bit
more some more winning chances
maybe King Ashwin was better he am
always in the somehow in those potential
checks yeah but maybe it's not a huge
problem
[Music]
Queen III may be starting to threaten to
check me there
going to be five would be good somehow
to cover everything I don't have time
though what to figure it out
she's threatening to check in to me so
he has to do this and now hmm I cannot
cover that pawn steps that's really the
case mmm that is a shame that's a shame
really that is getting away with this
and gets it wrong yeah not good
it's very disappointing you just should
win this game like yeah I should win but
yeah it wasn't it wasn't so easy maybe I
made stupid mistakes but okay yeah this
is some pretty pretty bad morning
actually c3 1974 I mean normal moves
idea for an advantage so this and I
think retreating makes sense
I should be 45 sending him back Oh Queen
d4r that's amiss ouch I should have done
that that is very strong no it has to
take and I can take with the Queen which
is super comfortable yeah I've got this
b3 Bishop b2 oh god no that's really
really strong for what I have a ship d3
is this terrible protocol when you you
you always be better here but it's not
it's not as much as it could've been
yeah and okay here it should be too was
the the alternative but I mean this is
also just a bit of an advantage
what he did is he blitzed all this and I
can't move move move
it's not funny really this position but
it was helpful at the end so if we go
here I mean I really would like to know
if I can convert better maybe I don't
have anything here to be honest that is
possible and I have to play something
like King f1 even though I mean are you
winning against Queen III it's did the
engine maybe but I have my doubts I have
my doubts
I feel probably the best that you can
get you with widest Sun four against
three at the end which unit not can win
you know probably this is not that easy
row and what does that mean maybe I
should take with the Queen actually and
play this ending right here here and min
before
yeah that's going to be four against
three almost surgeon named tickle but
look you talk see - maybe not maybe
actually I can do something against the
C pawn here I'm not certain at all yet
you get four against three for sure here
yeah him and that's wrong with good play
for black with good play by black it's a
draw I have to take probably and now do
this and this I'm not totally certain
about because this is still bid week and
I can try to get the King in it's not
going to be able to get rid of it it's
the thing I mean you can go here I could
play Lucy - of course this is funny what
is the engine doing here you have to do
this simply stops the C pawn and now you
can try to bring the King over and maybe
try to prove that this is weak but black
still has pretty good drawing chance
nothing ok thanks for watching